well i i hope we're getting there and by
the way you mentioned a word that i
think is the most important word you
said
and it's something that my therapist
constantly right before i go okay
uh good talking to sandy and she's like
gratitudes say your gratitudes
say your gratitude and i'll tell you i
go to bed and i'm if i'm stressed and
whatever and i just close my eyes and i
go i thank my grandmother for freaking
unconditionally loving me
i i thank my you know all of a sudden
and it's bet better to go it's better to
go to bed with good thoughts in your
mind and it really helps me
it does that's wonderful i can work that
into my
sleep training and for myself that
really uh eric i'm telling you that's
i'm not the most disciplined guy in the
world but i do just try to when i go to
bed
i lie in bed for a minute and i just
think of everything i'm grateful for
and then somehow i fall asleep and the
next thing i know it's the morning or
sometimes it's four in the morning i go
eat a peanut butter jelly sandwich
that's so beautiful though yeah i mean
cole
will ask the kids you know what was your
favorite part of the day
but to make it broader even than that is
great yeah by the way for the adults
also that's more necessary the kids
naturally go i had a great day and i
love you and you know
that's true